I don't know that we have someone for
you
I find that controversial hey if you
don't get take your beautiful titties up
out of here bro yo take them gorgeous
ass knockers they're milkers from the
heavens and get the [__] up out of here
what's your name Alex Alex
why are you wearing sunglasses inside
people in my eyes but I'll take them off
though I got you thanks
it's like going on a date and you got a
hoodie on the whole time
like can you sure you don't think that's
just [__] weird of course it is yeah
so uh
[Music]
yeah so yo uh so what do you like to do
for like for fun what kind of date is
that
she ripped her butthole freshman year of
college huh
she rips
three painful months before seeing two
doctors
I fully regret putting that in my
application
yeah I mean just freshman year even
dining hall food afraid to like use
public bathrooms just like didn't go
well and something bad happened one day
and what
what
she was eating she was eating dorm food
or something what she was afraid of
public bathrooms she refused to [__] for
three four weeks and someone came up
there he's like you like California
[Applause]
and that was September and I had to wait
until I went to my doctor at home so oh
there's a lot of pain for a long time
yeah nothing embarrassing ever happens
to you
not particularly I'm a pretty smooth
individual if I'm not lying to you
[Music]
why did you reject Elgin I feel like you
have to have something more embarrassing
hello how are you I'm Haley
God damn titties
they were there yep titties present they
roll their [__] back just hello how are
you I'm Haley I'm Jamil nice to meet you
I really like she went hello in the
tease went oh
maybe that's just me making up physics
in my head hello anyway no yeah zombie I
don't know I felt like if I saw titties
doing this I'd just be like
zombies hey girl Hello titties
not even hey girls and titties you're
not even talking about a girl you
talking to the titties your titties are
out there I might just say hello hey I'm
Jamil nice to meet you nice to meet you
too never mind
nice to meet you too she went like this
no shagging the cat no
we can't get here I like the tattoos
thank you so much they just got them do
yours mean something to you the Sun and
Moon that I have
okay
well what sign are you
we're gonna go straight to it I'm like
sorry bam I could have Shawn I mean
that's astrology why
uh and you can be honest I can handle it
I would say I'm not sexually attracted
to you it's gone good how are you good
Bernard Bernard I'm Haley Haley all
right it's also Reynard Renard I'm so
sorry uh it's like the French word for
fox bro Bernard listen listen listen
listen
okay you coming out here saying Bernard
nobody believes you no matter how many
Hawaiian shirts you wear that [__] not
gonna change foreign
what's your name
they went in the middle Africa fetched
up a messiah Warrior and be like put
them jeans on I think I know who this
guy is this is
yeah
are you Muslim yeah that guy I think
it's him I think he's like Sudanese or
something wait what's your name
I already said it you forgot
can I show it for something
you're a Muslim
[Music]
he went Muhammad Ahmed Allah
this [__] said Mohammed three
times
and while Muhammad appeared in the
mirror you understand what I'm saying
and she asked are you what's her name
Muhammad Ahmed Muhammad are you Muslim
no my last name is James III I'm
Christian
[Music]
I'm definitely a monogamous type of
person yeah I just it felt bad yeah it
doesn't like that idea I know I feel
like we revived it
it was gonna come out anyway come on
I'm Haley Mark I've heard you've been uh
buzzing a few people you have some
things to say about it no no I
understand it I like picky so how old
are you 23. how old are you I'm 30.
that was a low-key this he said 23 and
she went what can you talk about
[Laughter]
to catch it that was a dish what what
like you 23 you can't talk about much so
uh what do you like Pokemons digimons
what what's your thing
uh yeah that's a this that's a this
every time I pause I just started back
to looking at it of course but I was
gonna say are there any type of
philosophers that you would say you find
yourself really akin to or that like
really you have influenced you
uh Kanye West Steve Jobs and my father
Kanye West Steve Jobs and my father
that's not the most [__] 23 year old
[__] to say yeah that's almost gen Z
loser and [__] Steve Jobs you're 23.
how long has Steve Jobs been dead for
well not enough for him to remember yeah
I mean like this guy must have been in
his mid teeth something about Steve Jobs
that's what what this [__] look at her
iPhone every day be like wow
I love those blue boxes I don't even
know if it's for original I don't even
know if any messages
he creates culture he creates
conversation he changes people's minds
and he's anti-semit like and he's
against well but but the thing that was
yeah I know I know I I know but as far
as Kanye West really shook me all that
was really hard oh my God we're gonna
take a break from the men hello
[Applause]
why is this funny we were just playing
truth or drink in the dressing room
and Chris just
um had a question of who would you be
most sexually compatible with out of
this group
and lo and behold it was me
yeah so I didn't you're training to uh
to become a certified sex coach
it's so cool I think there's a lot of
healing with sex and there's so much
shame behind all of them
[Laughter]
there's so much shame
shame forever
so it's okay no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
still looking at titties
Jesus Christ my dude you got issues with
titties I appreciate some Natty I'm
freezing some good daddies I'll say this
there's something funny about like the
people are always like empathy and
kindness and this and that and like the
moment you force them to make a choice
they go as Cut Throat as anybody else
being like get the [__] up
what you mean it's either this or like
they can't choose but it's really the
fighter this is a safe space yeah you
can say who said that the previous video
she said that no previous video we're
going to talk about a different girl
different video or not no but the people
who always do this oh this is the same
space you can do that they often are the
ones who are the most ruthless oh yeah I
I love I love a sensitive [__]
yeah disagree I think that people are
whenever they they save Spacey the most
of them they actually do not want to
choose because they don't want to look a
certain way
it's really two people the ones that are
like super rootless but there's a lot of
people because they don't want to be
that person I don't want they don't make
they often don't ever [__] make
decisions and it's actually like Ugh to
just talk to them like you just make a
[__] decision but I don't wanna I
don't want I don't wanna then they can
never make a decision not on the button
I've seen it they say oh I love trans
women oh I'm really open to this yeah
forces people to actually be honest
because when they don't want to lose you
know and so all this talk about I'm kind
this is safe you can say anything you
won't be judged and they immediately hit
the button now that's these
[__] on this show this this
show literally exposes people all this
[__] about like oh
I'm open to anything
the missing the button like a million
times oh yeah uh you know there's so
much shame regarding sexuality it's like
man they're not really about it no we're
an amazing person thank you you don't
even know her see you're such an amazing
person shut up
I am into people
I'm into their energy never mind what
the [__] I said you just said hold on
hold on hold on you just like you made
me lie because it made me [__] lie
because I was we were rooting for you
because you just said you were not
particularly with the woman and are you
gonna say that you're into people you're
not into people you gotta type the
number of times that you buzzed the
number of times you but you have a time
what about for you yeah for me I don't
know I've mostly dated men but I find
women immensely attractive I I'm
actually more attracted to women than I
am men you're making me laugh you're
making me lie my girl cause you're
saying it oh my God I'm into people
you're sick I'm into people but they
have to be tall they can't be too young
they can't be too old they got to be hot
enough they can't look to this they
can't look too Brown they can't look too
confused between Bernard they can't be
too Bernard they can't be too big
monogamous they can't be two I was like
oh [__] you're not into people bro
never mind you until one percenters like
I said and I don't mean money-wise I
mean like really different your choice
doesn't reflect what you actually you
masquerade it into something that is
very general I'm into people but then
your choices doesn't show that my girl I
think that
ironically enough
her blessing is her curse what do you
mean
titties cool yes being born with those
titties has [__] her up
that's really [__] her up you got an
issue because it's giving her a level of
arrogance that is like
you think of arrogance it is compounded
by the existence of her titties you
think Italian I would say
with those things yeah
or the reason why she gives the
attention she gets and because she gets
the attention she gets and reinforces
whatever view I don't think an ugly
woman could have nearly as much
weirdness like this as her if she's
Untitled she gotta have something you
can't be that ugly but she gets hers I
know this girl gets whatever she wants
when she wants it you wanna know why
yeah because titties yes with those she
goes on a dating app she's getting
thousands of swipes but you take those
teeth without those titties you you
should subtract you subtract yeah cause
you can take a good selfie with them
titties and I'm gonna be honest with you
to the roof oh yeah who doesn't want to
suckle on those
but if she didn't have those I think I
think
I'm gonna be honest with you
probably yeah we're gonna say like sex
love did you find each other attractive
she does not find her attractive she's
gonna lie about it because
you want you want to know how I know
because I saw what she looked like when
she found somebody attractive aka the
real tall black dude girls smiling she
was yes queening everything now she's
more monotone
stunning
I think you're absolutely gorgeous thank
you
you both said you found each other
attractive but you were both ready to
hit the button you see this you see this
she did not answer the question yeah she
didn't say see the button says you both
said you found each other attractive but
you were very ready to hit the butt okay
she didn't say she found her attractive
she said she's gorgeous which in women's
speak just means no no I want to say
something nice okay the other girl
didn't want to hit the bunch she saw the
other girl reaching and she also reached
for it mind you
you have to notice something and I said
that just right before we cut it right
I said she gonna say she's gonna say yes
because it's a girl she's gonna lie
because it's a girl right because with
the guy
she was ready to be like nah you're not
my top no you're not I I don't find well
if you might say you're cute which
depending on the context can be a bit
yeah exactly I your cute is I'm still
ready to buzz you understand what I'm
saying here we go let's hear the truth
I feel like I would have more fun with
you as a friend like let's go wow same
place Vibe same just because I'm
attracted to you doesn't mean I want to
[__] you yeah am I going to get this
person's information absolutely
absolutely are we gonna [__] probably
not probably not maybe you know what
Never Say Never Enough tequila possibly
I'm glad the button called that out I'm
really glad okay Haley yes
I don't know that we have someone for
you
I find that controversial
oh if you don't get it take your
beautiful titties up out of here bro yo
take them gorgeous ass knockers the
milkers from the heavens and get the
[__] up out of here I never want to see
those beautiful
volunteers things again you got you got
issues
that's not controversial you did that to
yourself I don't even see how
controversial that is it's not
controversial that is not a controversy
also why are all the polyamorous people
always funky looking because because
they funky you know I mean like
irrespective of my homegirls audacity
like mostly people I see they look funky
when they're they're polyamorous they
just need something about them a little
bit the haircut the team well the thing
that happened is first they come from
Seattle so I think it depends on where
they're from I don't every polyamorous
person I've met has been a little funky
looking I'll be honest maybe I'll feel
differently y'all ever notice that
forget the blue hair whatever like a lot
of them just look a little bit you know
you didn't notice that